[Music]
joining me today is the senior editor of
the Atlantic a contributor on MSNBC and
the author of the new book Trump
accuracy the corruption of the american
republic david frum welcome to the rubin
report thank you so much for having me
I'm glad to have you here I've wanted
you on for a couple years I think at
this point you were a tough guy to track
down but we made it happen
I'm findable I'm not in hiding yet
you're not in hiding yet you could be
maybe by the end of this interview
because I let my guests talk and you
never know right now that's the Twitter
formula that you're like 140 characters
away from career self-immolations yeah
well we've got about 60 minutes we'll
see about emulation immediately all
right so a lot of things I want to talk
to you about I thought your your
personal history is interesting and
usually when I see you on television
you're talking about the the day-to-day
machinations of politics you are
Canadian I did not know that I find that
I like Canadians everyone does why are
you people so agreeable because they're
so passive-aggressive I grew up in
Toronto I'm just we have place in Prince
Edward County which is about 2 and 1/2
East out of Toronto two hours east of
Toronto where my wife and I and our
children are spent summers now for
almost three decades Canada is a you
know is a kind of mirror image of the
United States with some things omitted
some things intensified and so I think
it offers Americans often a kind of well
what if examination of what the United
States might have been under different
circumstances yes that's an interesting
phrase what do you think so mitad and
what do you think's intensified in well
so Canada didn't have the American South
didn't have slavery didn't have a Civil
War Canada had a peaceful separation
from Great Britain so it doesn't have
the mill it doesn't have the kind of
citizen military traditions Canadians a
very different attitude toward guns I
mean they're my neighbors in Prince
Edward County all have are not all but
many have long guns hunting pieces
shotguns but the idea of having a
a military style weapon is a very alien
idea for Canadians yeah do you think
some of the Canadian attitude is also
that just there's a lot of geographic
space and not that many people actually
yes well there it can be kind of it can
be kind of spooky tonight I mean they're
they're great city so Canadian Canada's
much more urbanized place in the United
States
Canadians are more likely to live in
Toronto Vancouver Calgary Edmonton
Montreal those places but and there
there's a I mean a line from a poem the
wild is always there and even when you
live in the center of Toronto you can
head off you can start driving and
pretty soon you you're in the wild yeah
interesting so your mom was on the
Canadian Broadcasting YES Network or
company CBC Canadian Broadcasting
Corporation Corporation okay
Linda from tell me a little bit that's
my Linda promise my sister who's a
member of the Canadian I think things
are different no no but she's a very
prominent person to Linda from as a
member of the Canadian Senate leader in
the Canadian Conservative Party my late
mother Barbara from was the host I heard
correct here keep my biography Keaney
arresting you on your back she was a
radio interview on a show called as it
happens for a decade and then was the
founder of a show called the journal
which was one of those face-to-face TV
shows at a time when satellite instant
satellite communication was quite new
she died in 1992 at the age of 54 was
your family always political I mean it
sounds like probably right well but my
family was interested in politics my my
late father was a businessman not not
involved in the political world and he
had a lot of distance from from politics
but yes I mean my parents dinner table
was a place it was a high-pressure
environment and they they thought deeply
about things but they were not
ideological and one of the one of the
places where I really I mean learned to
think was around that dinner table
because you know my my mother's very
skeptical about everything including her
own children
and the way she when you were saying
something she didn't like but she would
never argue with you which you just set
marching these two lines of
interrogatory questions and you would
eventually realize I'm caught between
these two
lines and she would force you to think
more deeply about and not just political
things but about everything why do you
do that why do you say that
why do you think that's funny and it
made you a more conscious person and I
try to live up to that in the way I
raise my own children you never try I
try never to tell them what to do or
what they what to think but instead to
challenge them to think and to think
more deeply and not just about the big
things but about everything do you think
that's what we're fundamentally missing
in society right now I mean I think it's
what I try to bring to this show I try
to let my guests talk even when I
disagree with them and maybe poke and
prod them in ways to to learn a little
bit more but that everyone in the media
these days is just pounding at each
other and hitting each other and trying
to destroy each other instead of sort of
going along that journey with you and
figuring out why you think that way and
yeah and more importantly how you think
I think it's just human nature I think I
think it's human nature to be tough on
others and soft on ourselves and it it's
a real discipline and to say you know
what maybe I should be soft on others
and tough on myself so there's an
interesting story I want to get this
totally right when you were 14 you
volunteered for the Ontario New
Democratic Party yes so far so good so
far so good and for those who don't
follow Canadian politics as closely so
the Ontario NDP is the Left Party in
Canada it's a multi-party system and the
canid of course has a parliamentary
system and there was a provincial
election and I was interested in seeing
how politics worked I wasn't I didn't
really have political ideas but I was
interested in campaigns and I
volunteered on that back campaign so on
that campaign you're 14 years old and on
your commute you're reading The Gulag
Archipelago well it was a bus subway
streetcar you know it was really
something for a volunteer right it was
summer holiday and so my mother had
given me as a birthday present the
paperback edition of The Gulag
Archipelago and urged me to read it and
so I had a lot of time on that commute
and it had it hit me like a bomb and I
think I mean my family you know
we're not my parents got I would have
Europe my family my families got out of
Europe before the war but they left
people behind it's Poland Poland but so
most of my father's family were
annihilated in the Holocaust and very
fair was something was always very
conscious in my mind and then here was
this other story that I had not heard so
much about and it it saved me how does
that shape a 14 year old well it if what
it makes you aware of is that human
history is very tragic that you can't
wrote a lot that power can be abused and
it makes you begin to think very hard
but well how do we build a society and
so there I was on the Toronto subway
system in a society that really worked
and it forces yet I think most societies
aren't like this in most societies
people are exposed to random terror and
to dictatorial power how do you make
societies that that work and that
protect people and respect human dignity
and human freedom
so I began and of course at 14 you have
no answers but you can you become
interested in the question and what you
also know is that when people say I have
a great scheme for Humanity it just
requires a few prison camps way you
learn you know what it's probably not
such a good scheme right although they
usually don't tell you it requires
prison gifts it usually tells you
requires a lot of good things right I
mean isn't that the real trick but it's
currently but it tells you at at there
are warnings early on they're warnings
early on in any utopian project like
that we're going to have to you know
break break some eggs here to make no an
omelet and at first you're right at
first the eggs are not at first the eggs
are kind of small but the the first you
but you can tell those steps and that
one of the things that you know I mean
this is I think one of the reasons why
people look at what's happening on
campuses with such alarm because you
know obviously those are the people who
are shouting down people on campus they
don't have police forces but they've
made it pretty clear how if they ever
did have a police for exactly how they'd
use yeah so when I first came across you
I think it was
maybe 10 years ago you were on real time
a lot and I would say I would just see
you on different televisions and it was
probably when for me personally I was a
little more left than maybe I am at the
moment or at least the whole Overton
Window has just shifted that it's hard
to put anyone on the traditional map
anymore but I always sort of you always
struck me as like a sensible
conservative I never watched you and was
like ah that's the guy I disagree with
on the right you know in some like
crazed way what what does conservatism
because you you are conservative right I
would say I would use the adjective I am
conservative my I've stopped using the
noun a conservative interesting that's
an interesting distinction and it makes
sense to me relative to so many things
changing right now
what does conservatism generally mean to
you well I think it starts with the way
our brains are built that there are
people who are more conscious of risk
and they're people less conscious of
risk the people who hanker for change
they're people who are ready to stick
with present evils rather than try new
ones and that's just a matter of brain
chemistry then when people with those
different brain chemistry's approach the
problems with society they start
building systems of ideas so the reason
I stopped using the phrase a
conservative and stop talking about the
conservative movement is what I would
have called conservatism when I came out
of college in 1982 was a set of answers
to the problems in the 1970s and 80s
inflation crime the Soviet menace the
disorder in American life a sluggish
productivity growth and the
Conservatives of those days had a series
of policy recommendations for those
problems and by and large they weren't
and the result was that the problems
either were overcome or anyway so
reduced in significance they stopped
being the most important problems in
Americans karaduman
new problems came to the fore and about
those new problems conservatives had the
same old answers they've had back in
1982 and it became a kind of fetish that
if lower taxes were the right way to
respond to low productivity growth in
1982 then if you had completely
different problems in 2008 and obviously
still lower taxes must be the same must
work just as well as they did before
completely different set of problems in
1982 so I think what is what has
happened is that the conservative
movement on conservative politics is a
fossil it's it's it's interesting in
that reveal it's like unearthing some
piece of rock from a different
geological era it tells you something
about what people had on their minds in
1982 but if you say how am I going to
solve the problems of 2018 not so
helpful yeah so when people say that
they're conservatives now does that have
any particular meaning to you like I
guess there is the set that you're
talking about from 82 that's going you
know we know what the answers are then
but that seems very different from now
and then of course we're obviously gonna
spend a lot of time talking about Trump
and that really is flip this on well
well this is what is made from possible
this is why the conservative movement
has sort of worked itself out of a job
so the actual content of conservatism as
you know what does conservatism have to
say about the opioid epidemic what does
it have to say about the Great Recession
what does it have to say but the
collapse in life expectancy among
non-college Americans what does it have
to say about America's place in the
world
in a world in which we're no longer
competing with an ideological nuclear
superpower of the Soviet Union but with
a with these opportunistic actors that
like Russia and China as conservatism
has become more useless to help those
problems what what it has been left
behind is an attitude what conservatism
I think means to most people say I'm a
conservative
it means anti leftism find out what the
what the American Left is talking about
at any given moment and not only think
the opposite of it but actually make
your opposition to that that group of
people the organizing principle of your
politics your sort of defining principle
basically your defining principle now
what that does is first it makes it does
a couple things first it makes
opposition ISM it means you're always
against never for and the second thing
it means is you never have the
initiative because you don't know what
you think about anything until somebody
else tells you first and I think that's
one of the reasons why conservatives
were so vulnerable to trump is the
you had an intellectual estate that was
largely untended and falling into
disrepair
and Donald Trump came and kicked the
door down and moved in
were there any candidates that you liked
that of that crew before Trump came in
and wrecked the whole thing look there
been a lot of I mean I've almost always
supported well until 2016 I always
supported the Republican nominee for
president and I thought there have been
a lot of people who have had real
promise to make a good precedent MIT
Romney would have made a very very good
president conservatism problem a
republicanism problem has been that you
take people who are have real promise as
leaders and you then connect them to a
program that can't win a democratic
election you know since the end of the
Cold War conservatives won the
Republican nominee for president has won
a majority of the popular vote exactly
once that was in 2004 in the aftermath
of 9/11 it's no longer there's no longer
a national majority for what Republicans
are offering and what has happened and
it's no surprise because one year said
well our big idea is to take the
Medicare guarantee away from everybody
under 55 to put Medicaid on the path
toward extinction and to use all of that
to finance more tax cuts like those that
worked in the 1980s in a completely
different set of circumstances that
you're not talking to or about me so
good people have been committed to an
unworkable program and what has happened
then has been that as Republicans have
lost the parties become more desperate
and we're vulnerable but when it's also
happened is that you have had a an
increasingly self-conscious move in the
conservative world and this is part of
the trump acqua see when I talk about in
the book to say well if we can't win a
majority of the people what we are going
to we're going to cope with that by
redefining who the proper people are
we're going to define the country we're
going to shrink our definition of who
are the people and divide the country
between the people and
those people and the people and if we
have a majority of the people that's all
we care about and we're going to try to
find ways to prevent those people from
participating in even voting so it's a
couple things there so it's interesting
you mentioned taxes a couple of times
generally speaking when I have
conservative sit across from you there
for tax cuts no matter what and that's
what you're saying that there was the 82
Cru basically that was sport and then
this fossil remained and people are
always for it now but it's it's rare to
sit across from a conservative and
you're basically saying that there are
instances at least where the tax cuts
are not a problem yeah but what one of
the really damaging things I mean
societies have states states need
revenue so there are their thing their
ways you know the United Sates might not
need so much tax money if for example it
didn't spend twice it twice as much per
person on health care as everybody else
in the world I mean you look at the
actual dollars the United States spends
on on health provision for terrible
results it's very expensive
conservatives by and large are not
interested in getting their fingers into
that problem they're not so the
government needs revenue and it has to
be funded and part of the fossilization
happens it's conservative say you say
we've got a problem whatever it is and
consider well if I can solve it with a
tax cut then I'm for doing something if
I can only solve it by having a spending
increase that I won't do anything
well then happens it's cynical operators
say well what if we take our spending
increase instead of doing it through an
appropriation we do it through a tax
credit how do you feel that oh then I'm
fine right and the result is that
whether the problem is housing or higher
education or caring for disabled
children that conservatives can be sold
a solution in the form of a tax credit
which is usually the least efficient way
of solving up a problem and the result
is we that you get this kind of
malformed state where the United States
has a really big and expensive
government but it's financed in
especially inefficient ways and it
addresses problems in especially
inefficient ways so
is the first part there though that
nobody actually cut spending you know
I've had been Shapiro in here a bunch of
times and that's what he talks about
that we can keep raising taxes forever
and ever and ever but that really we
have this just giant monstrosity of a
government that's incredibly inefficient
I mean even health care aside just
everything all the mid-level bureaus and
regulators and just this massive federal
government that was never supposed to
get so big that we never actually really
look at how much of that we could chop
away at where then if we did a little of
that we could have the the sort of
relevant conversations about tax cuts
that you're talking about well that's
partly true and partly not the United
States what does the Unites States
government's spend its money on defense
Medicare Medicaid Social Security
I think that's those things together I
think that's about 80 percent so the
rest of the government you know is I
mean I think it's true that dollar for
dollar the US government is less
efficient than that of other countries
mostly because of the inheritance of not
having a proper civil service that the
idea the president starts off by
appointing the top 10,000 jobs in the
civil service this is highly political
and you get a lot of people who
shouldn't basically have no background a
government don't know what they're doing
and things are not done in a very
efficient way also the power of Congress
means there are a lot of people who are
always trying to you know put in some
special benefit and things happen that
don't make so you have military bases
and places where they shouldn't be
but if you were this is this is why I
say conservatives volitans obsolete if
you want to reduce the state's share of
expense and really I mean not just by
repackaging things as tax that are right
you know that I mean one of the ways we
for example fund the care of disabled
children is through a series of tax
credits that are not labeled as
expenditures but really are you have to
do something about Medicare and Medicaid
and so the conservative idea has been
okay well the answer is we're going to
take away Medicare and Medicaid
people and the reason that the Obama
period has been such a crisis and the
period after its is the defeat over the
defeat of the conservative attempt to
repeal the Affordable Care Act and to
pass the Ryan plan means the
Conservatives have to now face a world
in which the United States has joined
the other developed countries and having
something like or something closer to a
universal healthcare guarantee the old
idea will save money just by not
covering people that is not going to be
workable in the politics of the 21st
century so that means you have to
actually pay attention to how Medicare
works and you have said how while
covering everybody do we squeeze costs
out of the system and that requires a
commitment to policy detail that
conservatives don't like to do as they
like the sweeping comment we just need
to cut all this waste but the when you
say well where is the wasted Medicare
well the answer is with the United
States over pays for all of these
services per unit and doctors make more
money in the United States than they do
in other places you have you have these
but you also have this problem if you
have a sicker population they're not
people do in other countries Americans
die earlier they're less likely to our
seatbelts they have more gun accidents
you have to delve to deal with this
problem you have to delve into detail in
a way that the conservative preference
for ideology over factual specificity
makes conservatives not very useful at
is anyone good at that these days though
really like really saying you know we
had look if you look at the real
grassroot movement on both sides I mean
Bernie was pretty extreme left and Trump
was whatever it's hard to call extreme
right but we'll get into that whatever
you call that that you know just the
wrecking of the system so you have two
competing forces look we have a lot of
political messianism that's a really
important point but here here let me put
instead of looking at what that the two
sides of if you were to take the
thousand people in the United States who
know most about Medicare and Medicaid or
the hundred who know most about Medicare
and Medicaid I'm guessing 90 of the
hundred and nine 990 of
thousand maybe not 900,000 would be
people of the center-left because
conservatives just don't care about that
kind of knowledge and so they're always
at a disadvantage that they look that
they don't care they just don't think
the government should be involved in
this like that the fundamental bloke at
worst well okay yeah it's not the job of
the government really but they know so
every once in a while somebody will put
his head above the parapet and say I
don't think the government shouldn't be
providing health care for everybody
right you lose an election that that is
how Donald Trump became the Republican
nominee that's what Paul Ryan does not
think the government should provide
health care to everybody mm-hmm the
problem is the Republican primary voter
thinks the gut well the government
should provide health care to everybody
but they should provide health care to
everyone like me so yes they should
provide health care all the over 65s
they should provide health care to all
the veterans but you're once you do that
you're into a very big program and once
you're saying government should provide
health care to all the over 65s that's
where most of the spending takes place
yeah anyway so just to be clear you have
a ideological difference with maybe the
Paul Ryan approach but you think it's a
legitimate way of looking at the
government right it's forward through
your mouth but certainly understand it's
a way to think yeah for sure
you could argue that point but it's not
a way that a political party that wants
to compete for power in the United
States conflic because the voters won't
accept it so what ends up happening is
that the Republicans have a bunch of
commitment they have a crunch of
theoretical commitments and a bunch of
operational commitments and those they
don't line up and in fact the Republican
Party does maintain Medicare it does
maintain Medicaid and it tries to find
little economies usually in not very
efficient ways but the result is because
it doesn't care about how those problems
work and it's not psychically committed
to them there is no one there saying
we're going to cut we're going how is it
that Germany and France and Switzerland
the Netherlands Canada cover more people
have longer life expectancies and spend
less you know they're not the difference
between what the United States spends
the difference of the American spending
the American economy in health care and
that of the other developed countries is
about three three or four points of GDP
which is bigger than the defense budget
mm-hmm so what does that say then just
about we don't even have to make this
about conservatives per se what does
that say about our system if a guy came
up let's say the Republican nominee came
up and really was talking about that the
ins and outs I mean no matter what let's
just look at 2016 I mean he would have
been clubbed over the head by trauma and
this still don't remember trub campaign
sorry Trump said Trump is a was a great
disco
this is what I mean by the hollowness so
Trump said I'm going to protect Medicare
I'm going to protect Medicaid Trump
campaigned as the guy who's going to who
was the first Republican who really made
his peace with the American social
insurance system when conservatives said
Trump wasn't a conservative they were
right and that's why he beat them inside
their own party Trump begins by beating
the Republican world he bins begins by
defeating Fox News and bending all of
them to his will now he had no idea what
he was talking about he had no plan for
executing any of this but he do you do
you think that's really true cuz I hear
this with a lot of people that he had to
either no idea what he was doing he had
no plan or anything
someone has are no idea yeah and reveals
that every day he doesn't know he
doesn't understand any but what does
that tell you about all of us yeah
that's true like is that saying one of
the interviewers had said during the mr.
Trump you say you're going to preserve
Medicare and Medicaid
what does Medicare do and what does
medically do and what's the difference I
will bet you the amount of money the
Republican party are going to corruptly
put in his pockets of mar-a-lago
that he couldn't have answered that
question yeah so that I completely agree
with I did a video before the election
saying if you want a stump Trump ask him
what the three branches of government
are and what they're supposed to do he
was asked what the three elements of the
nuclear triad are and didn't know that
so that kind of stuff I do agree but
this thing about sort of there was no
plan or is no plan I in some way even if
even if I can intellectually get there
with you there's something about that
idea that then he duped by I mean it's
scary
I guess I would say it's pretty scary to
think that someone who had no plan duped
the rest of us like that that inherently
seems like a plan at some level we
started talking about plans at different
levels Donald Trump is one of the great
scam artists of all time he scammed the
people Trump University he and the scam
was possible because of the
disillusionment of so many people with
responsible politics but what what he
intuited I mean I mean he's not that he
Dom Trump has certain talents and
geniuses I'm he is a genius at finding
the weakness in things and he understood
the weakness in the institutional
Republican Party which is that they were
offering a message that their own voters
hate it and I have a lot of detail on
that in the book about how when you
actually showed Republican voters
Republican primary voters what Paul Ryan
wanted to do they spoiled from it mm-hmm
but he's gonna take away my Medicare
he's gonna take away my mother's nursing
home that's the plan that's the famous
Ryan plant so Donald Trump understood
that that and what he then understood as
well was that in the absence of a
program that this ant he left is some
that had become what conservatism was
this was a series of resentments and
rages that were waiting for somebody who
had articulated who who raged and
resented as powerfully as they did I
mean Republicans the previous Republican
nominees would sometimes tap these
feelings try to channel them but they
didn't share them Donald Trump scarcely
okay so before we go fully into Trump
and then we're gonna spend the rest of
the interview on Trump I just wanna talk
a little bit about the modern Democrats
and and the left in general and all that
so what do you make of the the feeling
that he was going for I think that's a
pretty legit feeling on what's happened
with the Left related to free speech and
the endless hysteria and everyone's a
bigot a racist and identity politics all
of that that feeling I think is legit do
you see that as a legit feeling look in
our group Authority that feelings are
legitimate the question is are not even
feeling I see it as a legit reality
thing that he was talking about there's
a little collegiate reality I don't
think it what what behind behind all of
those things you described he's a new
fact in the politics the United States
in the past 15-20 years which is that we
are moving into a period of intensifying
ethnic competition for power for money
and for the right to say that that what
to talk about to define what it means to
be an American and the countries made
this big gamble on changing itself and
across the developed world countries
like the United Sates have made similar
Gamble's the proportion of the
foreign-born in Sweden is now as high as
in the United States the proportion of
foreign-born in Germany's nearly as high
as in the United States that are having
massive problems there are immigration
is all is a source of massive social
tension and we know a lot of the
immigration happened without anybody
ever consciously intending it and
without much of a debate over it and
with a refusal to tally costs and
benefits in an accurate way so these
countries have been changed and what you
have is then a series of new demands and
new resentments and that's one of the
one of the reasons that the conservatism
I grew up with the sellout of date is
look back in 1985 the argument between
liberals and conservatives was basically
an argument about the economy that and
this is true not just in every developed
country we'd have you had a party of the
people who worked for wages and the
party of the people who owned capital
assets and workforce alumns the left
were the people who whose jobs are
supported by taxes the right where the
people's jobs are supported by profits
if you're in management you were on the
right if you were in a union you're on
the left
not to sound Marxist about this but
essentially your relationship to the
means of production was the was the the
organizing principle of politics what
also happened in 1985 was it people
remembered that this kind of politics
could spiral out of control and they'd
seen it happened in the 1930s and and
you could get fascist movements you
could get communist movements and so
there were attempts to temper the
competition between the wage people in
the salary people between the owner
the workers that's and so you had that
you had kind of a accountant that the
left accepted a market economy and the
right accepted a social insurance state
but that's what the argument was about
and that's what we've run on now for
that and there's a plan some time but
that has ceased with the collapse of
socialism that argument ended the the
modern left is not really a socialist
movement anymore there I mean they
people will sometimes use the word
they'll have but I mean back in nineteen
fifty there are people who really
thought that if the government owned the
banks the banks would make better
lending decisions than they did then
they would if they're privately no one
thinks that now I mean I think really
you don't think that there's plenty of
people on the left I think that it's
just if so we'll just sort of
incrementally get there they have three
hundred and thirty million people you
know somebody who thinks every no no I
don't mean no one but I mean that if
that if Bernie was president that
eventually the you I think the creeping
movement of this yeah Elizabeth Warren
that do they want to movement I think
Elizabeth Warren does not want the
government down the banks Mel I don't
think she believed that Elizabeth Warren
does not think government should own the
steel companies she doesn't believe that
government should own the commanding
heights of Industry I'm sure she does
not bladder lettuce I don't know about
owning it but what about just
controlling it to the point where in
effect its ownership I know I know you I
know I don't have to think this a
co-owner I don't think she thinks they
should manage it she believes in a
social market economy I mean if you were
to say to her what is the best run
country on earth she breeding always
used to say Denmark was the best one
country Denmark is a free market Society
he's got a bigger social insurance
system in the United States and he said
that because the reason he said that was
he's never serious answered miss he
didn't he'd stopped caring but that's
not what politics is about what politics
is about is in 1985 if I knew how you
made your living I could probably guess
how you voted today if I know where your
grandparents come from I know how you
vote so if your grandparents did not
belong to the local ethnic majority
whether in the United States or Germany
or Britain you are in the party what you
used to be the left if your grandparents
do belong did do or did belong to the
local ethnic majority newer and what is
the power party of the right used to be
and that's true however you make your
living however much a little money you
have and that was not true
former days so you have this politics of
ethnic competition and that's why
politics as one reason why politics are
so much more virulent because you know
in the end you with money you can always
split the difference somewhere we say
will you take 20% no well you take 23%
what Oh
28% okay we have a deal right but when
you're competing what does it mean to be
an American
we haven't who gets to define American
this we haven't found a way to split the
difference on that and until we do we're
gonna have very very limp politics I
mean there's this you know when when the
Sarah Palin's and others talk about what
it means to be a real American some
things are real American other things
are not they're looking for a way to
claim ethnic legitimation that we get to
you know we may not have the numbers
anymore but we still define the country
and that is one of the things that's
going on as what these political
correctness battles are all about I mean
it's it's always true that there are
things people don't say you know all
these things that people don't say even
if they're free to said there are things
they don't say how does that happen that
though they're things that you don't say
and who gets to decide and that's what
we're struggling over the people what we
are calling political correctness is
people think there used to be a set of
rules about of taboos we have a new set
of taboos we want the old taboos to be
unta boo and we want to impose the new
taboo and the people on the receiving
end of that say we like our old taboos
and we don't want these new taboos and
that that's where Donald Trump is is
coming from I mean if that's a real
dispute it's important but it's it's new
and it's dangerous and we don't know how
to manage it and we have this deeply
opportunistic actor who's are taking
advantage of it okay so before we fully
dive into that then what does this show
you that our brand of multiculturalism
which has worked better than virtually
any state you know European state are
our melting pot does this tell you that
the experiment is starting to fail I
mean is this the the litmus test for
that well you know because that's what
it sounds like
first the American melting pot never
worked as well as Americans told
themselves
it did in that states
has had a lot of civic conflict in its
history and not just the civil war and
then later 19th century had the most
violent labor relations anywhere on
earth and those are often about
ethnicity that the strikers would be
from one group and the police police who
shot them would be from a different
group and the strikes would be broken by
strike breakers who are from a third
group yet again but multiculturalism is
difficult to do and it's especially
difficult to do when you have moved out
of the age of mass production and was
one thing when you're bringing in you
needed a lot of bodies to run a modern
economy you don't need so many bodies
today and and we also live in a world in
which whereas before there were a lot of
pretty average-sized rewards today we
live in a world in which they're
gigantic rewards and not such great
rewards and the average what what the
average person gets is not as attractive
relatively speaking as it was two
generations ago
[Music]
you